la côte d'ivoire en deuil le premier
ministre amadou gon coulibaly chez
décédé hier à abidjan à l'âge de 61 ans
l'homme politique a été victime d'un
malaise en plein conseil des ministres
c'était le premier événement depuis son
retour en côte d'ivoire la semaine
dernière transplantés cardiaques en 2012
mady koniba les avait quitté son pays
début mai pour la france il avait subi
deux opérations
l'actuel président alassane ouattara qui
quittera le pouvoir après deux mandats
elle avait choisi comme son successeur
aux élections présidentielles prévues le
31 octobre prochain
on écoute le secrétaire général de la
présidence ivoirienne
je rends hommage à mon jeune frère mon
fils amadou gon coulibaly qui a été
pendant 30 ans mon plus proche
collaborateur je salue la mémoire d'un
homme d'état de grande loyauté de
dévouement et d'amour pour la patrie
avec la disparition d'amadou gon
coulibaly la côte d'ivoire perd un
modèle pour la jeunesse
un exemple de compétences d'ardeur au
travail et d'abnégation que son âme
repose en paix